-Yeah. Oh, look at that.
-Hello. How are you?
You didn't get the memo.
-[ Laughs ] I should have.
-So I'm just --
How much of a fool do I look?
-No, you -- I can't believe --
Of course you would do this.
You're the best.
-This is how I walk around
my house all the time.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-I insist everybody who comes
to the door has to put one on.
And know how to tie it --
that's the other thing.
-Yeah. So it's classy,
but it's also dressed down.
It's both.
You know how to do it.
Today is James Bond Day.
-That's right.
-There's no better way
to celebrate
than with James Bond himself.
I'm honored.
Thank you so much for coming.
-Pleasure is all mine.
-Oh, please.
-Thank you for having me.
-It was announced on Friday that
the release of "No Time to Die"
is now being pushed
till the spring.
And I have a question for you.
Be honest.
Is this just because
you want to be James Bond
for a few months longer?
-Just eke every second I can
out of it.
-Yeah.
-Here's the deal.
This thing is just
bigger than all of us,
and we just want people
to go and see this movie
in the right way and safe way.
You know, cinemas, you know,
all around the world
are closed at the moment,
and we want to release the movie
at the same time
all around the world,
and this isn't the right time.
-Yeah.
-So, you know, fingers crossed,
April 2nd
is going to be our date.
-It's such a big film.
-Yes.
-And all of these Bonds are,
but they have been ever since
you took over 15 years ago.
They're just the most insane --
Every movie would top each other
with the next one.
And I'm just like --
You know, some people go like,
"Oh, my gosh, why wouldn't you
just want that gig forever?"
I'm like, "Because
it's hard work. It's crazy."
-You know, I mean, there
comes a time where, you know --
I've given it everything I can.
I'm so glad that I came back
and did this last one.
We had lots of loose threads
that we hadn't tied up,
and the story,
it just didn't feel complete.
And I just was so --
You know, I needed a break,
I'll truly admit it.
I just needed to kind of get my
head away from it for a while,
and once I had and we started
talking about story lines
and things that we could do
and where we could take it,
I was like, "Oh, look, I'm in.
Let's do one more
and try to sort of, like,
finish the story."
We started the story
in "Casino Royale,"
and actually we've
kind of been very -- You know.
I think we very successfully
kind of continued that story
all the way through.
And this was the chance
to just round it off.
-Do you remember
when it was formally announced?
You can take it off. Sure, sure.
Take it off. Yeah.
Do you remember
when you were formally announced
as the next James Bond,
when it was official?
-Yeah, I mean, I will never
forget any of that time.
It was some of the most
exciting, dramatic --
all of the things --
time of my life.
I was in -- God.
When it was
officially announced --
That's just now I think
it was officially announced,
like, 15 years ago, like this
week or something, or next week.
-Yeah, it is. Yeah.
-But I was in Baltimore
filming with Nicole Kidman.
And Barbara Broccoli,
the producer of the Bonds,
one of the producers
of the Bonds,
phoned me up and just said
to me, "Over to you, kiddo."
-Oh!
-But this is the thing.
You know, I was in Baltimore.
I had a night off.
I had a day off the following
day, and I was like,
"Well, what am I going to do?
I can't tell anybody."
I couldn't tell anybody
because it was like --
She said, "Don't tell a soul.
Don't tell your family.
Don't tell."
So I'm like...like --
So, I was in
Whole Foods supermarket
literally with a shopping cart
with deodorant
and washing liquid
and, you know,
doing my weekly shopping.
So, I literally pushed that
like, you know,
down an aisle like that,
and walked into
the liquor section.
I bought myself a bottle of
vodka, a bottle of vermouth,
and a shaker and a glass.
And I went back.
And this is the thing.
You may not believe this.
I'd never had a martini before.
I'd never mixed myself
a martini, ever.
I'd never actually drunk
a martini before.
I kind of understood
what it was,
and I was like, "Okay.
I'm going to give this a go."
People talk about --
It was in Chicago I think
when I was doing
"Road to Perdition"
when people were drinking
martinis --
the first time I'd ever seen
a proper martini.
And I did actually taste one.
Then I went,
"This is just vodka."
And they went, "Yeah."
I said, "Very dry."
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Yeah, it's so dry
that it's just actually vodka.
-It's just a glassful of vodka!
Let's be honest.
So I did half a bottle and
stumbled to a bar in Baltimore,
of which there are many really
many good bars in Baltimore.
-Yeah, I love Baltimore.
-If you put a gun
against my head,
I couldn't find the bar again,
I was so drunk when I got there.
And I sat and I must have drunk
another three martinis
at the bar. And the guy --
I must have been smiling.
I just must have been, like,
from ear to ear.
And the guy kept on saying,
"What's going on?
What's going on?
You're in a good mood."
I said, "Listen,
you wouldn't [bleep]
believe me if I told you."
-He's like,
"This guy's crazy, man.
What is -- He's just laughing
going, 'I'm James Bond!'"
-I must have literally --
I must have been...
I can't imagine.
I must have looked crazy.
I mean, the fact he even spoke
to me was probably, you know --
-But what a tough thing
to keep secret.
And you're just like,
"Oh, my gosh."
But, I mean, there is one person
you did tell,
which I love this story.
You told your mom.
-Yeah, of course.
I mean, you know, I did.
And then she got --
Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
I told my mother, and she
then got done by the press.
Because she is
very tight-lipped.
But, of course, she got a phone
call from "The London Times,"
who basically said,
"You must be very proud."
And she was like,
"Well, of course I'm proud."
And then that's it.
-That's all they needed.
-Daniel Craig's mum
announces Bond.
-Confirms it.
-Which is not actually,
when you think about it,
not a bad way to get announced.
Is it, really?
-Everyone is going to be
asking you about what you will
miss most about being Bond.
I was going to ask you,
what's the one thing
that you won't miss at all
about being James Bond?
-Um, I don't get out very often,
but sometimes
I will be somewhere,
maybe in a hotel lobby
or somewhere,
you know,
where there's a bar maybe.
It can be literally 9:00 a.m.
in the morning.
And a martini will be shoved
in front of me.
And I'm like --
Back in the day,
there may be a time
when a 9:00 a.m. martini may
have been a kind of nice thing.
But just -- I'm just not.
They don't go down so well now.
9:00 a.m.?
I love a Martini,
but 9:00 a.m. is a bit tough.
I won't miss that.
-We have an exclusive clip
from "No Time to Die"
that we're premiering right here
when we come back.
I've actually
never even seen it yet.
It's a special link.
So I'm freaking out.
Thanks for this.
Stick around, everybody.